اذا قلبه ينبض في المستشفى واسمه ينبض في
المدرجات تقارير من هنا ومن هناك عن تدهور
الحاله الصحيه للاسطوره البرازيلي طبعا
نتحدث عن فيليه الذي يرد الترد الانباء
بانه قوي وحمل بالامل ومستمتع بمشاهده
منتخب بلاده في كاس العالم بيليه الجوهره
الذهبيه تصدر العناوين ليس فقط كوننا في
اكبر موسم رياضي لانه ملهم لنجوم السمبا
والعالم هو موجود في الملاعب بلافته كبيره
حملها الجمهور البرازيلي في مدرجات قطر
وفي رسائل جامده بعثها نجوم كره القدم
متمنين له تماما الشفاء عائله بيليه طمئنه
الجميع انه دخل المستشفى بعد اصابته
بكرونا ولا يوجد هناك شيء يدعو للقلق بشان
بصحته بيليه الجوهره السوداء شخصيه
الاسبوع في صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
اديسون دوناسيمينتو اسمه والده بهذا الاسم
تيمنا بالمخترع توماس اديسون لكن اصدقائه
في المدرسه اطلقه عليه نتيجه عدم لفظه
لاسم الحارس البرازيلي فيليه بشكل صحيح
هذا الفتى النخيل الصغير صنع تاريخا يصعب
تكراره داخل المستطيل الاخضر بفوزه بثلاثه
القاب لكاس العالم وبطل كهذا بالتاكيد
يحمل قصه استثنائيه فهو من اسره فقيره
عاشقه لكره القدم اصيب بقى في صغره عندما
كان لاعبا محليا ورفض النادي الذي لعب فيه
والده تحمل تكاليف علاجه فاعتزل وعمل ماسح
احذيه ولانه جوهره جذب انتباها مكتشفي
النجوم ينضم الى قطاع الناشئين في نادي
مدينه باورو ليتالقه 100 هدف في ثلاثا 33
مباراه فقط لاختفى النادي العملاق عام 56
عام 19
58 واجه المدرب في سين تي فيو الاعتراضات
على اصطحاب الفتره السبعه عشر عاما لخوض
مونديال السويد لان بلاي اصبح اصغر هداف
ثلاثيه شخصيه او هاتريك واصغر لاعب واهداف
في المباراه النهائيه في تاريخ كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا الصحافه الرياضي
محمد حامد والنقاش يدور حول المساله
التاريخيه التي لم تحسب من هو اعظم لاعب
في التاريخ ونبدا طبعا بالمربع الذهبي الي
اهلا بك مارادونا ميسي رونالدو يعني كره
القدم معروفه انها اكثر الرياضات شعبيه
حول العالم هناك عظمه لهذه اللعبه ابهر
الجمهور حقق ارقام قياسيه وحطم الالقاب
باعتقادك من هو اعظم لاعب
بكل الاحترام
للجيل الحالي ميسي ورونالدو واساطير العصر
الحالي بالنسبه لنا
هي المساله سهام تسمحيلي مرتبطه بفتره
عشق كره القدم اللي بتتشكل لدينا في مرحله
عمريه معينه يعني عمر المراهق خلينا نقول
مين كان اللاعب
المتربع على عرش الكره في هذا الوقت مين
هو النجم في هذا الوقت انا مثلا ابني او
بنتي هيقول ميسي او كرستيانو صح لي هيقول
مارادونا اجيال اقدم ممكن تقول بليه
وبالمناسبه ليه في حاله جدل حوالين فكره
انه من افضل اللاعبين في التاريخ لانه
اجيال كثير لم تحظى بمشاهده بمشاهده
بالليل بشكل مباشر بس دلوقت ما فيش مبادره
انت دلوقت سامع مني او سامع منير اكبر ان
بليه لاعب اسطوري جوجل روح اليوتيوب
على مستوى اذا تكلمنا من الناحيه الفنيه
في ليه كان مهاري بشكل لا يصدق لا يصدق
عنده اولا لياقه بدنيه غير عاديه عنده
مهارات فرديه عنده ارتقاء في ضربات الراس
عنده دقه تسديد عنده رؤيه في التمبير كل
ده كل ده مجتمع في بليه بس ممكن يجيء حد
من المعسكر اخر شبابي اكتر يقول لك كره
القدم لم تكن بهذا التعقيد كره القدم كانت
هجوميه في هذا العصر لم يكن هناك عدد كبير
من المدافعين مارادونا مثلا محاط بثلاث
اربع لاعبين ميسي في العصر الحالي محاط
يمكن 15 لاعب مع ان الكره في 11 لاعب فقط
يعني هي الفكره اصعب همم الكوره رايحه
اكثر لفكره همم
خلينا نمنع التسجيل مش نسجل فبالتالي مهم
في المهرجين اصبحت اصعب ده من ناحيه
الفنيه
هو اعظم لاعب كره قدم في التاريخ ونرجع لك
[موسيقى]
عشان هو عمل كل حاجه في الكوره كاس عالم
وبندق عمل كل حاجه في الكوره وهو ما هي
اكثر من اي لاعب
يدخل عليه بيبقى خائف هو كده كده
كاس عالم
ليو ميسي طبعا بالارقام كله
مارادونا لاعب كبير
بيعرف يتحرك بالكوره ازاي بيمر بالكوره
ازاي بيعرف يسجل ازاي الراجل بيخترق اي
دفاع ازاي
متكامل برده بيجيب اهداف اهداف
تحس ان هو بيعمل حاجه مختلفه حاجه انت مش
متخيل ان هو يلعبها ازاي ف ااا حقيقي فعلا
ان ممكن اي لاعب مثلا يتعوض ثاني يعني
عندك مثلا رونالدو ممكن يتعوض مثلا
همم
اسطوره اسطوره الله يرحمه يعني يعني طبعا
من الناس اللي هم سطروا التاريخ في كره
القدم انما نجيء للوقت الحالي او العصر
الحالي طبعا همم بالنسبه لي يعني رقم واحد
وعشره محمد صلاح
يعني ده اعظم لاعب في العالم دلوقتي
[موسيقى]
على الارجنتين تونس فازت على فرنسا
والمغرب تمكنوا من الفوز على بيلجيكا
واسبانيا نقطه مهمه الجيل الحالي
مع العالم اكثر من اجيالنا عنده قدره على
التفاعل عنده قدره على انه يخترق مدارات
العالميه انا بنتي عمرها 19 او 20 سنه لما
بقعد احتفل بشكل مبالغ فيه بصراحه عندها
رد بيعجبني ههه
شوف الفكره يا سهام يعني الجيل الصغير ده
الجيل الشاب اللي موجود في المنطقه حتى
على المستوى السياسي حتى على المستوى
الاقتصادي جيل عنده قدره على التخاطب مع
العالم بجراه طيب
تاثير مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في تحديد
عظمه اللاعبين كريستيانو رونالدو اكثر من
نصف مليار وتابع مواقع التواصل انت تكون
لصالحهم وامتى تكون سيئه ضدهم مثل ما شفنا
مع بيليه وغضب عيلته من اخبار التعزيه
وتغريدات التعزيه
الامر فيه محورين مهمين جدا مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او حسابات احنا عندنا في العالم
4.7 حسابات السوشيال ميديا يعني تقريبا
60% من من من من سكان العالم عندهم منصات
خاصه بهم كل واحد اعلان كل واحد اعلام
فبالتالي مساله مرجعيه اللي اعود لقناه
معروفه مثلا اقعد لويس سايد معروف او
جريده كبيره اصبحت قليله شويه هم بيلاقوا
الخبر بيبتدوا يتداولوه دون تدقيق لمصدر
الخبر هذه المساله خطيره جدا يعني بين
كلمه كم مره يعني يعني
تخيلي رد فعل عيلته رد فعله هو لانه شخص
صحيح عمره 82 سنه بس نشط على السوشيال
ميديا تخيلي الشخص ان يقرا خبر وفاته وعلى
قيد الحياه صح دي من التاثيرات السلبيه
السوشيال ميديا خلينا نقول ما يتعلق
بكريستيانو رونالدو سريعا مقارنه حتى مع
ميسي ميسي لاعب خارق مهريا وكره قدم لا
يقارن باحد يعني فجوه هائله بينه بين
كريستيانو رونالدو ولكن في نقطه مهمه
كريستيانو رونالدو عنده ستوري صح عنده
خارج الملعب شيء يحكي عنده شيء يشد
الجماهير وبالتالي انا كصحفي لو طلب مني
اكتب كتاب او بايغرافي عن ميسي او رونالدو
شكرا لك